hi Honey hi I love your shoes I have
that
dress what's going on oh is the baby up
no you sleeping
yeah how's your
day I'm getting nervous why I don't
know what what's going on I don't like
these
meetings I have a surprise for you
I'll be right
back I'm so worn out with these
surprises the last time I was in this
situation I was introduced to
[Music]
Phoenix you're
joking so at this point I don't know
what to
think
[Music]
your favorite that's
it I thought you were going to go get
another
blanket I love
Chanel I just know that you love to
carry around so much stuff with you so
what do we say what what's going on we
have another surprise
you have another
surprise don't even start with
me
o you ready I'm
ready
[Music]
no
no are you kidding
me
wait what this is your grand doggy
babies wait what this is diamond and
baby
diamonds
clones oh my God how cute are they oh my
goodness oh my
goodness Carter found this company they
just can take a dog cells and they can
make your same exact dog it's been 10
months since Diamond baby ran away and I
just feel like part of me is missing
Diamond baby baby
Diamond she was like my sister my best
friend my sidekick and I'm so happy and
grateful that Carter figured out a way
to get her back wanted to give you all
an update we've had two puppies born for
you a twin girls Phoenix you want to
meet Diamond baby are two little sisters
it's just a dream come true did you
think it was Diamond I saw the one
little head so I just thought it was
Diamond baby
you came out I didn't see until you were
sitting down and then I thought it was
London and I thought how she can't do
that to me again
um I've just been thinking about it a
lot I just feel
like I love you so much I feel closer to
you than ever I feel like we've just
come so far and
I just feel like I have a whole new
relationship with
you but I
feel that I want to do the same thing
that I did with Phoenix and make it a
surprise for
everyone you want to make it a surprise
it's when
you you everything you just
[Music]
r